تمرير قرار التقاعد رغم كل تلك
الاحتجاجات. المانيا في اهداف
لايران اذا خصبت اليورانيوم فوق
مستوى ستين بالمئة. طالبت مائة
العنصري اشارة الى اسرائيل. شهدت
العاصمة باريس وعدة مدن فرنسية
يعيد ويكرر خطابه نحو سيول
وواشنطن. اردتم المزيد وها هو
الاوكرانيسكي. وبعد زيارته
لباخموت ها هو يزور خرسون ويتعهد
لطول بالكم يا ابناء العم سام.
روسيا لا تلتفت لتصريحات واشنطن.
لتؤكد ان اليورانيوم المنظم ليس
مشعا ولا يشكل تهديدا نوويا. فيا
وها هي وزارة الدفاع الروسية
تعلن اطلاق صاروخ جديد من طراز
بخصوص التنديد الروسي بسبب ذخائر
بريطانيا المحشوة باليورانيوم
البيت الابيض من ان نجاح مبادرة
السلام الصينية في اوكرانيا قد
دول اخرى حسب قوله. ومن خطط
الحرب الى وقائع السلام حيث يخشى
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
اذا دخل اراضيها ليأتي الرد
لم يتراجع بل على العكس في تزايد
بحد تعبيره. واردف ان مذكرة
من تسليم وزير الدفاع الروسي
وسام الشجاعة للطيارين الروس
الروسية اعتراض طائرتين
امريكيتين من طراز الاستراتيجية
ليأتي هنا الرد الروسي ولكن
بضجيج المحركات في سماء
ترفض السلام الصيني في اوكرانيا
فهل هناك سلام مخصص للامريكان
تصب الزيت على النار وتقرب
الهشيم من الحريق وكان الحرب في
ايران فكيف سترد طهران؟
والمغربيون يطالبون بانهاء
وفنلندا تقترب من الانضمام
للناتو والكرملين يرد بقوة.
الامريكية وموسكو ننصحكم بضبط
اعصابكم قادم ليس في صالحكم.
اخرى اضرابات واغلاقات واحتجاجات
حاشدة بخروج اكثر من مليون فرنسي
اخترقت بشكل غير قانوني المياه
الاقليمية في بحر جنوب الصين دون
الخطوط الحمراء الصينية كما
اعلنت بكين لذلك قامت بمراقبتها
وفق القانون واطلقت انذارات
لابعادها من جانبها واشنطن نفت
والتطورات. قال وزير الدفاع
الكوري الجنوبي لجونكسوب ان
امامكم. نقل موقع اكسيوس عن
مسؤولين امريكيين قولهم ان
سيوز تو بوينت وان يحمل قمرا
عسكريا. فليدخل هذا القمر في
اسرائيل ابلغت واشنطن ودولا
غربية انها قد توجه ضربة عسكرية
شخصية مغربية الحكومة بانهاء
التطبيع مع دولة الاحتلال والفصل
قلوبكم ايها الفنلنديون. لتعود
واشنطن للرد على موسكو ولكن
كوريا الشمالية اطلقت اربعة
صواريخ كروز على الرغم من ان
كييف طلبا للحصول عليها. وتتجه
هيلسينكي لاستبدال مقاتلاتها
بكين ورد واشنطن يلعب بحر الصين
كمسرح لهذه النزالات. الاحداث
التحليل التفصيلي لا يزال جاريا
لتأكيد مواصفاتها وكأن كيم جونغ
الروسي كان على لسان المتحدث
ماريا زاخاروفا مجددا. حيث قالت
اخرى بين واشنطن وبكين لتستمر
محاولات حرب النفوذ التي تدور
ان قرار فنلندا الانضمام للناتو
غير متزن وستكون له نتائج عكسية
تحت ما سمي الخميس الاسود وذلك
رفضا لقانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد
نهاية الطريق. هنا في بحر الصين
الجنوبي ترتفع امواج الصدام مرة
الحادث جملة وتفصيلا على لسان
متحدث القيادة الامريكية في
بحسب وكالة الانباء الفرنسية.
بينما يصر الرئيس الفرنسي على
المنطقة. ووصفت البيان الصيني
بالكاذب. مضيفة ان امريكا ستواصل
عملياتها في المنطقة جوا وبحرا
القانون الدولي. وبين تصريحات
للوراء ولا تراجع للصين. وان
كانت المواجهة مع امريكا هي
الذين اسقطوا المسيرة الامريكية
ام كيوناين واصفا الطيارين
حروب موسكو القادمة ليظهر في
الجهة المقابلة الرئيس
باتريك فايدر يعلن ان القوات
الامريكية تواصل عملياتها فوق
من اعادة تجهيز السفن بصواريخ
كاليبر بشكل كامل بعد انفجار
بطائرات اف خمسة وثلاثين
المتطورة. لكنها بالمقابل تمنح
الطائرات القديمة لاوكرانيا بحسب
الوزير الفنلندي. فيال قساوة
روسيا تتحدث بلغة القوة. خطواتهم
تقيم الحرب ولا تقعدها. عملياتهم
اوكرانيا لا فهنا المتحدث باسم
وزارة الدفاع الامريكية العميد
العلاقة مع الكيان الاسرائيلي
وفرنسا تشتعل وماكون يتوعد.
رحاها بين الطرفين. المدمرة
الامريكية يو اس اس ماليوس
وللمرة الثانية الطائرة الروسية
تتحرش عسكريا بالطائرات
منا. ودولة اوروبية تعطي بوتين
الضوء الاخضر وترفض قرار
باعادة اعمار ما دمرته الحرب.
الصين تهاجم عسكريا. لا عودة
اذا سمحوا بمضي عدوان روسيا على
اوكرانيا دون عقاب فستنتهك سيادة
تمنح اوكرانيا طائرات هورنت
المقاتلة على الرغم من تقديم
موسكو النووية. فهل تقترب صواريخ
المرعبة من دك برلين? هل الامر
الذي تلمح له يا هذا ليجيب
ميدفيديف بتهدي بشكل علني ان
البوصلة الروسية نحو فنلندا.
وهنا وقع الرئيس الفنلندي سولي
الامريكي على لسان وزير الامريكي
انتوني بلينكن الذي قال بانهم
اقرب للواقع
مينيستو القوانين الخاصة بانضمام
بلاده الى حلف الناتو. الرد
موافقة السلطات الصينية وفق جيش
الصين. هناك تجاوزت المدمرة
لا تريد مواجهة مع روسيا. على
الاقل قبل انضمامها للناتو وها
على الوضع الامني والعسكري
والسياسي في المنطقة لكن فنلندا
هو وزير الدفاع الفنلندي انتي
كاكونين يؤكد ان على فنلندا الا
تجعل الصين قادرة على اقناع دول
اخرى في العالم بان الولايات
المتحدة غير مهتمة بحل الوضع
اوكرانيا وفق بلومبيرج. لتتجه
اندلاع ما سماه بالجحيم النووي.
مضيفا ان خطر اندلاع حرب نووية
يوم يزيد فيه الغرب امداد
اوكرانيا بالسلاح فانه يقرب من
فالقادم اعظم. وهنا نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الروسي يصرح ان كل
موسكو ستضرب الالماني ومكتب
المستشار هناك بالنووي اذا تم
انحيازها للطرف الروسي وتكون اول
دولة اوروبية تؤكد انها لن تعتقل
اعتقال بوتين يا الهي ما كل هذه
الحدة في التصريحات. لتعلن المجر
توقيف بوتين تعتبر حربا على
روسيا النووية حسب وصفه. فما
نعم انها ماريا زاخاروفا حيث
قالت لكير بيضبط اعصابك يا جون.
موضوعنا. وبعد ان اعلن المتحدث
الامريكي جون كيربي واضحة غضبه
تعجز دولة عظمى كروسيا عن ايجاد
بعض الصواريخ? فلنعد الى
تؤكد ان روسيا وضعت خمس عشرة
سفينة في مهمة في البحر الاسود.
بالحمقى. ردت الخالة فرنسا فران
موسكو وصاحبة التصريحات الحاسمة.
لكن القيادة الاوكرانية شككت في
ان تكون القوات الروسية قد تمكنت
هو القوة وليس غيرها. فها هي
قيادة عمليات الجنوب الاوكراني
مخزن الصواريخ في شبه جزيرة
القرم. لكن برأيكم متابعينا هل
ليقول الروس هذا هو قانوننا ولن
تروا شيئا غيره. القانون الروسي
المواجهات وليس على وسائل
الاعلام. حيث اعلنت الدفاع
البحر الاسود والتحليق في
الاجواء الدولية بما يتوافق مع
فوق بحر البلطيق بعد رصدهما
تحلقان باتجاه الحدود الروسي.
القانون الدولي. فهل ينفع هذا
القانون اندلعت الحرب يا هذا
امريكية وقوات صينية. وبكين
حذرناكم ولم تسمعوا. ووجبة نووية
اخرى يقدمها زعيم كوريا الشمالية
لامريكا وحلفائها. تقترب من ضرب
الجنائية الدولية وبحر الصين
يشتعل مجددا بمواجهة بين مدمرة
بينما وزير الدفاع لندي يعتذر
للجيش الاوكراني لا طائرات لكم
وخمس عشرة سفينة روسية عسكرية
تتحرك صوب اوكرانيا. وواشنطن